my parents sent me a card with a
native-american girl on it because they
get me thanks parents welcome to Tuesday
on its grace let's talk to you pictures
are just getting better and better
what am i calling this day talk back
Tuesday talking tits Tuesday - Tuesday
chit chit chat Tuesday who cares let's
get started with okay
where are the tweets and the three Polly
Howard new person to person to person is
probably that don't know in a new person
comments on any of my social media I
praise the crap out of them and welcome
them to the it's great family we hooked
like we are cubes Holly Howard more like
Howard Johnson University is a cool
school do you go there probably not
because you're so damn friend you but
boy how does Chris helping through the
thing with their face that makes it
perfect at all times so much makeup look
when I take my makeup off that's what I
look like underneath it all you're
welcome
low-cost e92 new person to person to
person low-cost e92 more like little
costco what opened in 1992 and then it
grew up and now it's 13 years old an ism
[ __ ]
but you can buy a lot of bulk there
[ __ ] bulk what cool boy I know I'm a
little behind but I finally ordered my
camp Takota merch and the movie yes guys
oh no that was yesterday I just had a
conversation with myself real quick in
front of you captor cook calm
Cappy mal new person to person to person
Cappy mal more like cap Bernick is the
49ers quarterback and he looks like the
front end of a centaur boomer Burt
today's consisted of eating everything I
can find and watching grace Helbig on
YouTube excellent career choice now
let's go to tumblr that's right if you
forgot I am commenting on your tumblr
comments now so get on that fanfic set
up also please don't kill us in the
fancy hazing sexy Friday a new person to
person to person hazing sexy Friday more
like calling all the milkshakes to the
yard I've been hanging out with Flula I
think too much or not enough that guy
you but boy dear the anon who called me
and my best friend a younger Grayson
Michelle you've literally made my life
that's the best compliment in the world
oh that is very sweet if you guys didn't
know Michelle Berg so used to make
videos on the channel called Grayson
Michelle Michelle is a life coaching you
can go find out all kinds of things
about her I'm Michelle akin calm and I
was her birthday last week so
she got one year closer to the I know a
nun means anonymous what does Kanaan
mean there's a simple way to find this
let's go with this
what does cut none owe me Kanaan oh wait
come on a beginner's guide to Sherlock
fandom let's find it effective it means
the letter of the law or the official
standard against which something is
judged this is why I hate educating
myself I'm just gonna stop but don't you
ever stop always be learning ABL a blue
my favorite color is stripes new person
new person new person my favorite color
stripes more like me - did you make a
tumblr based on something I said in the
video Wow
[Music]
here we are now you're a boy don't live
in fear fear such an easy emotion and
there's so many things to do and there's
so much beauty to see so why not open
your eyes a little bit grace helbig did
I really say that when did you say that
yeah goosey you're shaking your head
like no there's no way I said anything
like that
I'd cool good job past version of me now
it's gonna YouTube okay
Alexa Noel new person to person to
person miss let's in the well more like
dis LexA oh now do my break Wow this
video was seriously the best mmm there
are better ones have you seen the one
where the mom hits the girl with the
ball in the front yard and she follows
her heart yeah I know it's a good one
Ben King new person to person to person
been king more like Bend Prince when
doves cry he's singing with me you're
the brakes you do have some people in an
older demographic men teenagers adults
can think you are funny too goose does
not agree hannah blilie new person new
person to person had a lily more like
Hannah PS
[Music]
you've impressed I honestly forgot about
Kingsley what how dare you well that's
that very talking to you today I hope
you have a great day camp Takota calm I
don't know but you ruined me new person
to person to person YouTube ruined me
more like or did it ruins you and turned
you into an ancient ground I'm
completely sober today alright so I'm
not great at writing emotional things
but here it goes I just want to thank
grace for keeping me happy and motivated
each and every day and giving us the
opportunity to make such great friends
you brought this great group together
and we love you so much thank you Gracie
Jordan left middle oh look at you you
guys look like Destiny's Child Trin
Destiny's children yay